ultimately like we don't currently
operate on two layers we have several
Emeco
like prime cursive brain layer which is
where all of our kind of impulses or
coming from it's sort of like we've got
we've got like a monkey brain with a
computer stuck on it that's that's the
human brain and a lot of our impulses
and everything are driven by the monkey
brain and the the computer of the cortex
is constantly trying to make the Montek
monkey brain happy it's not the cortex
that's steering the monkey range the
monkey brains during the cortex
you know the cortex is the part that
tells the story of the whole thing so we
convince ourselves it's it's more
interesting than just the monkey brain
the cortex just like what we call like
human intelligence you know so it's like
that's like the advanced computer
relative to other creatures like the
creatures do not have either really that
they don't have the computer or they
have a very weak computer relative to
humans
but but it's just it's like it sort of
seems like surely the really smart thing
should control the dumb thing but
actually I don't think it rolls this one
thing so do you think some of the same
kind of machine learning methods whether
that's natural language processing
applications are going to be applied for
the communication between the Machine
and the brain in to learn how to do
certain things like movement of the body
how to process visual stimuli and so on
do you see the value of using machine
learning to understand the language of
the two-way communication with the brain
yeah absolutely I mean we're a neural
net and that you know AI is basically
neural net so it's like digital neural
net will interface with biological
neural net and hopefully bring us along
for the ride yeah but the vast majority
about of our of our intelligence will be
digital there's a like so like things
like the difference in intelligence
between your cortex and limbic system is
gigantic your allylic system really has
no comprehension of what the hell the
cortex is doing you know it's just
literally hungry you know or tired or
angry or sexy or something you know
that's an ADD just and then it that
communicates that's that impulse to use
the cortex and tails the cortex to go
satisfy that then love a great deal like
a massive amount of thinking like truly
stupendous mal thinking has gone into
sex without purpose without provocation
without procreation which which is
actually quite a silly action in the
absence of procreation it's bit silly
the one why you doing it because it
makes the limbic system happy that's why
that's why but it's pretty absurd really
well the whole of existence is pretty
absurd in some kind of sense yeah but I
mean this does a lot of computation has
gone into how can I do more of that
with the procreation not even being a
factor this is I think a very important
area of research by NSFW an agency that
should receive a lot of funding
especially after this decision if I
propose the formation of a new agency
boy but people generally like the fact
that they have Olympic system and a
cortex I've met anyone who wants to lead
either one of them like a girl keeping
both that's cool
Olympic systems kind of fun tell us what
the fun is absolutely and then you
people generally don't lose the cortex
either
I still like having the cortex and the
limbic system yeah and and then there's
a tertiary layer which will be digital
super intelligence and I think there's
room for optimism given that the cortex
the cortex is very intelligent and
limbic system is not and yet they work
together well perhaps they can be a
tertiary layer where digital super
intelligence lies and that that will be
vastly more intelligent than the cortex
but still coexist peacefully and in the
end of an EIN manner with the cortex and
limbic system
you